also breaking tonight two Americans are
dead following a rocket attack at a
military base in Iraq many others
injured their national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin
developing as this developing story from
the Pentagon could even Jennifer
good evening Brett a senior US military
source tells me that two Americans and
one British service member were killed
when 15 rockets struck Camp Taji
military base 30 miles north of Baghdad
at least eleven more troops housed at
the Taji base were injured in today's
rocket attack according to a well-placed
military source and as of two hours ago
medics were still treating the wounded
I'm told this represents the largest
attack targeting Americans in Iraq since
Iran fired 16 ballistic missiles at
bases housing US troops in early January
days after a US drone killed the head of
the Iranian Cootes force Qasem Soleimani
the US military would not say who it
believes launched the Rockets at Taji
not wanting at this time to blame Iran
Isis doesn't have this capability I'm
told by an American military source US
military officials have worried that
Iran would target Americans in the
Middle East to deflect from their own
failed ability to contain the corona
virus pandemic at home which has already
killed hundreds of Iranians the highest
death toll outside China Brett Jennifer
thank you